which boy band would you want to perform
at your wedding
bts
yeah you heard that right machine gun
kelly wants bts to perform at his i do's
with megan fox it's hard to top that one
man the 31 year old musician made the
confession during a chat with ellen
degeneres where the daytime tv host
asked mgk some burning questions which
boy band would you want to perform at
your wedding
which boy band am i going to know the
most songs of for sure and sync but
what
what's like uh
which band do i surprisingly know all
these like facts about bts i met them at
the billboard awards they were like
stoked to be me i think i have a better
chance of getting bts to come
i don't know i feel like machine gun
kelly could get in sync to perform a
little this i promise you at his
upcoming nuptials
[Music]
especially after he proved he's a die
hard fan last month on instagram
[Music]
but also let's be real bts singing
butter would slay on the dance floor
legs are nice
smooth like butter like criminal
undercover dawn
like trouble breaking into your heart
like that at the very least we know mgk
is officially a member of the army and
we think that's pretty dynamite
[Music]
of course the rocker and the actress got
engaged back in january after more than
a year of dating
[Music]
the two met while filming midnight in
the switchgrass back in march 2020.
working with him is amazing he's so
charismatic and he's so naturally gifted
megan later starred in his music video
for bloody valentine i know i've got to
go but i might just miss the flight i
can't stay forever yeah he's not allowed
to have other hoes in his music video
it's the queen or no one
and last month mgk stopped by the late
late show with james gordon and opened
up about wedding planning when do you
think you're gonna get married
um
when they can
build me like a
red river with like
gothic
the location is hard trying to find out
yeah all that echoes what a source
recently told et that the couple wants
their wedding day to be dark yet
romantic
showing off their lux and sexy sides
with black and red colors but regardless
of the decor or finding a venue one
thing's for sure
they're a forever kind of love quote
megan and machine gun kelly know that
they are each other's soul mates so they
want to get married sooner than later
[Music]
you